Nóng, nhóm người đi ô tô cầu, nâng yên phá nhiều biệt báo trên các tốc ví sơn, trên châu.
Theo báo tối trẻ, nếu mà ngô tháng mấy một, ông mĩnh tiếp thải, chú tịch tập đăng sân hại sách nhận,
vừa người đơn tổ cáo tự phạp đến công an tự thành hoá và công an tự sáng miế sơn.
Để đe dây gị, những cơ quan này vào cuộc đều tra hành vi của dấu hiệu phá hoa trên tuyên các tốc ví sơn,
trên châu. Tập đăng sân hại con người kẹn theo đơn hình anh, video là cật chúng,
những hình anh này được gây lại của ngày 20 triển tháng mười, thời điểm trên, một nhóm người đi xe tải có cầu nâng,
mâm định số 3 mì sòng xe bụng tạm không, đi giọt trên tuyên cơ tốt nghe sơn, diễn châu,
và phá hết tòa bụng chính biệt các kết bảo hành viễn năm của tập đăng sân hại trên tuyên đường.
Tổng ra chị để thạc lên đến hành trăm chựa đồng. Chúng tôi đã kiếp đồng bảo hành viễn năm với bụng giá thông bật tải.
Tăng kết này, đặc bảo chung người tân được đi lại trên tuyên đường bất nhất và cũng tiếp kiệm cho nhà nước nhiều chiếp khi khách sinh
về phải duy tù bảo sự đường trong mười năm. Con những tấm biển gây tối hạt bảo hành mười năm trên đường,
chính là thăm kết công khai với người dân của tập đăng sân hại để người dân chự kép 3 sách chất lượng công trình của chúng tôi làm trong mười năm đó.
Ông hại mức xúc chính bài.